they've heard the appeals from president
zielinski to close the skies over
ukraine to save lives but so far from
the uk's foreign secretary and america's
secretary of state the answer remains no
if i were in president zielenski's
position i'm sure i would be asking for
everything possible
in his mind to
help the ukrainian people our goal is to
end the war
not to expand it
including potentially expand it to nato
territory we want to make sure that it's
not prolonged to the best of our ability
otherwise it's going to turn
even deadlier
involve more people and
i think
potentially even
make things harder to resolve in ukraine
itself and the latest atrocity changes
little the attack on the hospital
is absolutely abhorrent
reckless and appalling but the reality
is that setting up a no-fly zone would
lead to a direct confrontation between
nato and russia
until now the us government has been
hesitant about labeling any of russia's
actions as war crimes after mario poll
the evidence they're gathering along
with the international criminal court is
mounting to a point where it's
impossible to ignore
the needs for ukraine are more urgent if
the west won't impose a no-fly zone they
say at least hand over these polish
fighter jets so they can do it
themselves but even that's a step too
far for a west wary of being dragged
into the war by the back door
we don't believe additional aircraft is
uh is the most effective answer to
meeting those needs in the conflict now
look
sovereign nations can decide for
themselves
what they want to do but uh
but this idea the proposal of of
transferring these jets to our custody
then for then transferring to ukraine
that is something that we are not going
to explore right now
it isn't what ukraine wants to hear
for all of president zielenski's pleas
it is clear here at the state department
in the uk government in nato there has
been no shift in position on those big
issues of a no-fly zone or sending those
polish jets to ukraine it begs the
question if the bombing of a maternity
hospital doesn't change their minds
what will
the horrors of this war are playing out
on screens in homes around the world how
much more will people tolerate before
they demand stronger action from their
leaders that whatever the risks enough
is enough greg milam sky news washington